This parabola's vertex is centered at 5 comma negative 2. Great work if you've
found this as the vertex. We start with the basic graph y equals x squared. And
we can shift all the points down by subtracting 2 from that equation. Think
about the values of y and how they change. If you know that y equals x squared
is, then subtracting 2 from x squared will give you a y value that is decreased
by 2. Next, we shift the graph to the right by 5 units, by subtracting 5 from
the x term in the binomial. When finding the x coordinate when y equals
negative 2, we know that this part of the equation, our binomial squared, would
have to equal 0. We know if x minus 5 squared equals 0, then we would have 0
minus 2. So y would just equal negative 2. That's the y coordinate of our
vertex. So this means that we set our binomial equal to 0 to get an x
coordinate of our vertex, have x equals positive 5. Notice again that the sign
is different for the x coordinate of our vertex than the sign in the binomial
here. Our vertex has an x coordinate of positive 5, but the binomial has the
number negative 5. But the sign of the y coordinate is the same. The y
coordinate the vertex is negative 2, and we see negative 2 at the end of our
equation.